Peter Navarro Peter thank you very much
for being with us this evening I want to
I want to start good to have you sir I
want to start with asking you a little
bit about the WH Oh should the United
States not be part of this organization
anymore should we cut off funding the
president just outlined the huge
disparity between the money that we put
into it and the money that China puts
into it
yeah Arthur let me let me give you a
kind of a bigger look at the chessboard
here because the UN itself has 15
specialized agencies including the w-h-o
the World Intellectual Property
Organization things like that and what
China has been doing very very
aggressively over the last decade is to
try to gain control of those by electing
people to the top it's already controls
five of the 15 and also by using proxies
colonial type proxies like Ted rose at
the w-h-o and as you can see in this
crisis the damage that that kind of
control by China of a key Health
Organization has been just absolutely
enormous they suppress the human to
human transmission they refuse to call
this a pandemic they basically
discourage travel bans so I mean this is
this is one of the most serious things
we've ever seen and it all tracks to
China's view of the world and how they
want to control different types of
international organizations even as they
don't play by the international rules so
it's going to be up to the president to
look at this but Martha this is a really
serious issue the president is
absolutely right about this so let me
ask you this you know in the past we've
seen three major viruses come out of
China and so if we can't rely on the
World Health Organization we need to
perhaps have our own medical
professionals or assessments similar to
sort of the IAEA or something along
those lines where you have independent
people who can take a look at what's
going on in various countries around the
world to give us a heads up in terms of
the actual virus or the actual you know
future pandemic that's happening there
has been some criticism that maybe some
of those though
outreach groups don't exist anymore
under the current framework of the white
house organization is that something
that should be put back in place would
you say well I think the problem here is
soui generis to China I think any other
country in the world would have been
transparent about the problem would have
invited CDC people in I mean we lost
about five weeks because of China's non
transparency so if you're asking me you
know how are we going to fix this it's
really kind of more of a China problem
than anything else and I don't have the
answer at this point that's outside of
my lane all I can keep telling you is
that China's attempt to control
basically every organization within the
United Nations through their colonial
powers through bribery through other
things tremendous damage to this country
into this world okay there's been a lot
of discussion about the memos that you
sent out at the end of January and
towards the end of February to the
National Security Council here's what
Steve Bannon said about that he said
let's put that up there
he said the principle reason it is the
quote the principle reason that Peter
wrote this memo is to make sure that
real information got to the president
because the real information was being
suppressed by the chief of staff at the
time Mick Mulvaney is that true let me
make something crystal clear about this
memo because I heard a lot of chatter
this morning on some of the left-wing
side of the cable news that memo was was
a memo that went not to the president
but to a small distribution list to the
task force so people this morning who
were criticizing the president for not
bothering to read the memo or whatever
he never got the memo it was not sent to
him and what's interesting to me Martha
even as I was trying to present a
significant issue to the task force
itself the president was one step ahead
of me because as I was advocating for
the travel ban in that memo to the task
force the president was already moving
to do that
and he did that on January 31st so I
think that's what's important to
understand where this and what I can
tell you about that the task force
itself why that memo went there is that
there was disagreement and that's not a
bad thing I think party would go ahead
it was I just want it was addressed I
believe to the National Security Council
is that correct there was no task force
on kronum address well it was a National
Security Council that's that's not
exactly right that the task force began
kind of unofficially that Monday I
appeared Tuesday at the task force to
present the case verbally and based on
the discussion there I felt the need to
write that memo so that and the chiefest
to the NSC yeah okay did Mick Mulvaney
is Steve been and right did Mick
Mulvaney push back at you and did you
feel the need to push harder and that's
why you put this memo out is that true
or not true so what happens in the
Situation Room by definition Martha
needs to stay there I can tell you
simply that there was disagreement among
the task force about this and I tried to
provide some clarity with a fairly
straightforward analysis of the costs of
the travel ban which would entail
disruptions to business and travel
versus the the bigger costs in case the
the and we didn't know this at the time
but in case the the the seriousness of
the pandemic emerged so I think what's
important here is that the president
independently of that memo made what I
think been the history books will be
judged as the pivotal decision in the
crisis and it started in motion a set of
events that have led to the largest
industrial mobilization since World War
two it's led to the use of the defense
production act for the first time since
the Korean War to great effect it led to
a quarantine which we never done before
which and all of these things the
president got tremendous resistance but
as every day goes by we see that
he was exactly right in in in doing what
he did he has a greater sense of the
chessboard I think than anyone and I've
said then I've said this repeatedly
prior to the crises I think he will go
down as the greatest president in modern
history for his positions on trade and
immigration but I think in this
particular case what we're seeing is
somebody playing the chess game better
than anyone and Martha we just got a
beat this virus we are at war he's a
wartime president and all this stuff
about memos and things like that you
know we need to focus on getting
medicines to the people well absolutely
and that's been our focus in terms of
you know watching this virus and looking
at it it is instrumental at some point
to figure out you know how it all went
down in terms of the response which has
been you know I think very strong in
many ways with with the possible
exception of the beginning just just
whatever thank you yeah yesterday we got
9 million doses of hydroxy out to
Chicago Detroit New Orleans in New York
today as we speak or arriving that will
there will be another 8 million doses
going to 10 different cities this is
moving in Trump time these are the kinds
of things I do every day in an office
about 40 yards across the street and
we're gonna beat this virus all right
we're gonna talk about that drug as well
coming up Peter Navarro thank you very
much thank you